you open the book with a story of a
central Florida man Jamal Dunn who was
drowning and drowned while five
teenagers watched and laughed saying
things like you're gonna die and then
Jamel disappeared below the surface of
the water one of them said he just died
and the others laughed what is this
incident uh teach you about human nature
and the response to it perhaps yeah I
mean I think this is a really
really really sad story and it and it
and it highlights what I believe is a
it's a real problem in our world today
it's it's an empathy Christ
yeah we're living through an empathy
crisis and crisis yeah yeah and
and I mean we've we've talked about this
throughout our conversation we
dehumanize each other and unfortunately
yes technology is bringing us together
but in a way it's just dehumanized it's
creating this like
yeah dehumanizing of the other and I
think that's a huge problem
the good news is I think solution the
solution could be Technology based like
I think if we rethink the way we design
and deploy our Technologies we can solve
parts of this problem but I worry about
it I mean even with my son like a lot of
his interactions are
computer mediated
and I just questioned what that's doing
to his empathy skills and you know his
ability to really connect with people so
you think
you think it's not possible to form
empathy through the digital medium
well about
because the way the way we engage face
to face which is what we're doing right
now right there's the the non-verbal
signals which are a majority of how we
communicate it's like 90 percent of how
we communicate is your facial
expressions
you know I'm saying something and you're
nodding your head now and that creates a
feedback loop and and if you break that
and now I have anxiety about it
four legs
oh boy I am just synchronizing your
facial expressions during this interview
all right okay
look normal look human yeah
nod head yeah not head
in agreement if Rana says yes yeah then
not had else don't do it too much
because it might be at the wrong time
and then it will send the wrong signal
oh God and uh make eye contact sometimes
because humans appreciate that all right
anyway okay
uh yeah but something about uh
especially when you say mean things in
person you get to see the pain of the
other person but if you're tweeting it
at a person and you have no idea how
it's gonna land you're more likely to do
that on social media than you are in
face-to-face conversations so
um what do you think is more important
EQ or IQ EQ being emotional intelligence
in terms of uh in what makes us human
I think emotional intelligence is what
makes us human it's
it's how we connect with one another
it's how we build trust it's how
we make decisions right like your
emotions
Drive
kind of what you had for breakfast but
also where you decide to live and what
you want to do for the rest of your life
so
I think emotions are underrated
um but so emotional intelligence isn't
just about
the effective expression of your own
emotions it's about a sensitivity and
empathy to other people's emotions and
that sort of being able to effectively
engage in the dance of emotions with
other people
it was a dance because it is really
about that it's about sensing what state
the other person's in and using that
information to decide on how you're
going to react
um
and I think it can be very powerful like
people who are the best most persuaded
most persuasive leaders in the world tap
into
you know they have if you have higher EQ
you're more likely to be able to
motivate people to change their
behaviors
so um so it can be very powerful